الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب راجع
للعناوين بقوه خاصه من وقت الاعلان عنه
للترشح من جديد لكن ترامب اليوم في
العناوين الاسباب بعيده عن الانتخابات
شويه فالرئيس السابق بطالب بتعويض 50
مليون دولار ورفع الدعوه قضائيه في
الموضوع كمان واما خصومه الصحفي الشهير
باب ود ود ودار النشر سايمون
والسبب هو كتاب صوتي اسمه
بيحتوي على 8 ساعات من مقابلات خام عملها
الصحفي مع ترامب بين عامه 2016
و2020 وبينهم تعليقات صوتيه للصحفي نفسه
حاطينها كمان اعتراض ترامب رفعوا للدعوه
بحسب ما قال انه هو ما اعطاهم الاذن
الاستخدام التسجيلات هذه في كتاب صوتي وان
هو سماح فقط بانها تتسجل علشان الصحفي
يفرغ منها اللي يحتاجه يعني ويغتصب ويقتبس
تصريحات لترامب يحطها في كتابه اللي كتبوه
اللي اسمه فريج اا كتبوا هذا الصحفي عن
ترامب طرح كمان في سبتمبر 20 20 ترم بعد
الدعوه نشر بوست على منصه تروس سوشيل وكتب
فيها ان هو راح يواصل مكافحه وسائل
الاعلام الاخبار المزيفه الفاسده والكاتبه
وانه رفع دعوى قضائيه على ود ويرد ودار
النشر اللي تبعته نشرت الكتاب الصوتي
واتهامهم باستخدام صوته بشكل سيء وقال في
الدعوه انهم عملوا كده لانه صوته هو من
اشهر الاصوات في العالم ترامب الدعم خصومه
المؤلف ودار النشر كمان في بوست ثاني انه
نشرت تسجيلات في محاوله لاظهار بصوره
الشرير لكن على العكس هم اللي ظهر فسادهم
وكذبهم واكد انه مستمر في الدفاع عن
الحقيقه والقتال ضد الشر وسيبقى بطل
الحقيقه الرد من دار النشر والصحفي على
الدعوه جاء عبر بيان مشترك قال وفي انه كل
المقابلات مع ترامب كانت يعني النشر
وقالوا انه تسجلت بمعلم بعلمه
كمان انه دعوه ترامب ما لها اساس انه
مريضه راح يدافعوا عن انفسهم بكل قوه
وانهم موافقين انه القانون لمصلحتهم من
هيفوز عدد في الفتره الجايه
طيب خليني اقول لكم انه كمان مشاهدينا
النتيجه نحن هنشوفها خاصه من بعد ما كمان
قضى قاضي فدرالي بالمحكمه الجزئيه
الامريكيه يوم الخميس بعقوبه مليون دولار
على ترامب محامي بسبب قضيه رفضتها المحكمه
وكان رفعها ترامب و30
قال فيها انهم حاولوا اتلاعب بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 2016 لصالحها عن طريق تلطيق
سمعه ترامب وطالبهم بالتوقيت 70 مليون
دولار
[موسيقى]